[Music]
foreign
s dream of owning a home but the
combination of high prices and high
mortgage rates has convinced some people
that renting is a smarter bet one survey
shows that on average the monthly cost
of owning a home is now about a thousand
dollars more than renting experts say
that is among the highest premiums for
home ownership since the housing bubble
in 2007. Nancy Chan is here with more
Nancy good morning Nate good morning to
you it's a question many of us face and
it's even more confusing when the cost
to rent and to own are both expected to
keep going up so now as the busy spring
buying season ramps up should you buy or
rent
for Greg Morano proposing to Kayla Lewis
was an easy decision the question that
followed not so straightforward to rent
or to buy we talked about it probably
for almost a good three to six months
just in terms of apartment sizes Styles
locations but then I think it kind of
shifted to the home process it was
actually a little bit more affordable
than some of the apartments it's an
age-old dilemma and buying has long
seemed the smarter Financial move but
now with interest rates still up the
median mortgage payment is more than two
thousand dollars a month a record high
since 2009. in major cities it may be
cheaper to rent instead of buy like here
in Boston where the average monthly cost
to own a home has gone up by more than
30 percent compared to a year ago rent
is also less than the monthly cost of
home ownership in cities like Seattle
San Francisco and Austin according to
realtor.com as a single woman I just
wanted to let go of some of that
responsibility and the stress that's
involved with maintaining a single home
Chloe Moore had owned her Atlanta house
for nearly a decade when she sold it in
favor of renting a choice she says was
ultimately a lifestyle and financial
decision buying a house is not just a
sticker price absolutely there's upfront
costs and then there's ongoing costs one
of the things I like to say is that rent
the most that you'll pay and the
mortgage is the least that you'll pay
she would know she's also a financial
planner Moore says you should only buy
if you plan on staying in the home for
seven to ten years on top of the
mortgage payment you have at least 10
percent for the down payment an
additional five percent for closing
costs and at least six months pay in
savings for maintenance costs and don't
forget taxes make sure you have your
finances in order understand your
numbers and work with people that you
trust for Lewis and Moreno with the help
of their realtor they just closed on a
home in northern New Jersey I think
that's the dream everybody grows up with
right it's it's one day hoping you have
something you can call your own own and
finding your person which I found mine
nice and some more tips if you are
looking to buy set a maximum budget and
stick to it even with all the bidding
wars happening in some markets even now
also use the 2836 rule to know how much
house you can actually afford that is
when you spend a maximum of 28 of your
gross monthly income on housing and 36
percent on all debts I mean
homeownership is such a big sign of
making it in the American dream but
accomplishment yes yes and it's building
Equity but it's hard to meet for me to
let go that when you're renting it feels
like you're just throwing the money and
you don't get anything back in return
but you're saying it sounds like renting
is not is is not a bad option it's not a
bad option it seems like the Surefire
win has been to buy for so long but with
mortgage rates what they are right now
it is not as clear-cut in a lot of
markets and not to mention you have to
resale as well yeah about moving a lot
of fees yeah the cost of taxes also
don't forget the cost of insurance right
you break the bank but you don't the
rent money back I know you don't I know
yeah even if you're paying higher
interest if you own the home you are
getting that Equity at least a portion
of it every month that does feel good at
least I I rock myself to sleep on that
thank you very much